country singer Jerry McComb has a new
album called the way back in his new
single back before I knew you is making
its way across the airwaves he's
performing tonight at Stoney's rocking
country in Town Square and he joins us
now Jeremy what's up buddy how are you
good to see you listen We're In Cadence
right there I love it
hey first question your new album comes
out but you're on the road for like 180
days how do you stay on the road and
write a new album at the same time yeah
it's uh it's definitely a labor of love
you gotta find time and make time and uh
between weird hotel rooms and tour buses
and uh and green rooms like I'm sitting
in right now at Stoney's we take all the
time that we can to write when we can
we got a show tonight it's gonna be a
great show what do you do before a show
a couple hours away do you drink you
know hot tea do you work on your vocal
cords what do you do before a show man I
just found out about my 18th cup of
coffee and
um it's nice because there was a Whole
Foods around the corner so we don't
normally get that so went over there and
stocked up and and getting ready to
sound check and and go tonight so it's
always kind of the same thing man just
try to get out and move around and get
some exercise we've been sitting on a
bus for a few hours well your country
music has taken off what was it when you
first started performing as a kid were
you doing country music or your first
band was it something different than
country music you know I played like I
started a 50s band when I was 13 which
all the kids in my school thought that
was pretty weird
and then yeah it was always country
music I loved songwriters I love
storytellers everybody from Kris
Kristofferson to Jim Croce and Otis
Redding and and all of those guys that
always had a story to tell so the show
tonight is a lot like that there's a lot
of Storytelling a lot of interaction and
stuff that that I learned from my years
watching Comedians and studying comedy
and just the way that you can connect
and interact with the crowd we bring up
studying Comedians and working with
comedians you worked with Larry the
Cable guys his tour manager for some
time but I also heard did you two write
parody songs together
yeah we used to ride all of the uh the
goofy parody songs that you would do on
on his records and in his live shows and
that turned into me writing songs for
them the movie soundtracks one uh which
got nominated for a Grammy which kind of
got me my original record deal in
Nashville have you ever thought about
dipping your toe back into the parody
song world we need a new Weird Al I mean
Weird Al's awesome but we need we need a
new one for the new generation no man I
was actually hoping
[Applause]
could write a jingle for me those guys
were really good but were they awesome
yeah
we'll get them to do a jingle for the
show tonight man Jeremy thank you so
much for joining us hit up Whole Foods
there do some shopping at Town Square
and have fun at your show tonight buddy
yeah thank you so much we're excited to
see everybody appreciate it man Jerry
McComb live in concert tonight